wir zuschauer wir kennen natürlich
sofort wieder zurück in diese diskussion
zum eigentlichen schwerpunkt dieses
sozial parteitages aber die rede des
parteivorsitzenden york
die hat hier ja wie eine mörsergranate
eingeschlagen und hat zu diskussionen
auch schon am rande des parteitags
geführt und deswegen wollen wir auch
eine erste stellungnahme haben und die
haben wir jetzt schon angekündigt vom
ehrenvorsitzenden und vom vorsitzenden
der fdp bundestagsfraktion alexander
gauland ergaunern diese rede von
bergleuten war galt die dem prinzip
angriff ist die beste verteidigung
nachdem er ja in letzter zeit stark
unter beschuss war auch von ihnen es
ging zum beispiel um den rauswurf von
andreas kalbitz ist das jetzt die ist
dass der erneuten tsunami den wir da
heute erlebt haben das glaube ich nicht
dass es der mountain tsunami ist das
haben sie ja auch eine redaktion der
reaktion der des plenums gesehen das war
ja sehr gemischt
in der rede waren gute passagen aber es
waren auch teile darin die ich für
spalterisch haltern und auch sein
angriff auf die bundestagsfraktion habe
ich überhaupt nicht verstanden
wir haben dieses problem mit den
besuchern die wir nicht haben wollten
in der bundestagsfraktion gelöst und da
muss sich der parteivorsitzende nicht
bei einer rede die zusammenführen soll
in diese diskussion einmischen also ja
vieles kann ich unterschreiben
aber manches kann ich nicht
unterschreiben es ist mir zuviel
verbeugung vor den verfassungsschutz
wir müssen gegen den verfassungsschutz
kämpfen
und da hat es auch keinen zweck urteile
des verfassungsschutz sozusagen von
vornhinein anzunehmen
man kann über das wort corona diktatur
streiten
ich hab das gebraucht ich habe auch das
wort kriegs kabinett gebraucht das ist
ein begriff aus england bei george l und
das ist nun wirklich ein
kroatischer start es ist einfach
lächerlich wenn man dieses wort corona
diktatur gebraucht dass man dann schon
die verfassung in der bundesrepublik
gefährdet und das finde ich hätte er so
nicht machen dürfen aber das hat er ja
genau angegriffen in seiner rede die
wortwahl corona diktatur kriegs kabinett
gesagt stefan brandner mit dem judaslohn
für an die verleihung des
bundesverdienstkreuzes im bundestag ich
hier jetzt jörg merten wird rum krakeelt
und rum geprallt
eine mangelnde disziplin in der partei
hat er festgestellt das ist ja ein
massiver angriff auf die fraktion auf
die partei
was glauben sie wie wird damit
umgegangen werden
na ja vor allen dingen ist es nicht wahr
die fraktion rollt nicht herum sondern
es sind zwei besucher über zwei
abgeordnete von uns in das plenum
gekommen wir haben in der tat sich
völlig daneben benommen
das haben wir in der fraktion
aufgearbeitet und irgendwelche zensuren
von jörg leuten für die fraktionsführung
kann und werde ich nicht akzeptieren
denn wir haben das selbst aufgearbeitet
und die beiden abgeordneten haben ihr
fehlverhalten völlig eingesehen das muss
man nicht vor einem parteitag ausbreiten
das spaltet die partei auch die fraktion
obwohl die ganz einig ist fraktions
spalte ist es nicht sondern die partei
kann es spalten und insofern halte ich
diese passagen für verfehlt also das
heißt äußerungen wie ich habe kein jota
flow und gerade schon genannt von stefan
brandl die messer männer von frau weigel
vogelschutz die bemerkung von ihnen das
hat er im kopf gehabt also diese rede
geschrieben ich weiß nicht was im kopf
gehabt hat er hat ja all das nicht
erwähnt sondern hat ausgerechnet nur die
korona diktatur erwähnt das was sie
jetzt sagen ob es im kopf gehabt hat
weiß ich nicht dann muss man es
aussprechen
aber es geht nicht dass ein begriff den
man für falsch halten kann aber
jedenfalls der nicht verfassungswidrig
ist
zum thema auf dem parteitag macht
er hat gesagt es sei nicht klug sich
gemein zu machen mit den corona leugnen
von querdenken
er hat gesagt die können wieder quer
denken noch geradeaus denken das war
auch ein massiver eine massive kritik an
der solidarisierung mancher ihrer partei
mit den querdenkern wie sehen sie denn
diese position wie sehen sie diese
bewegung die ja zb bei den
demonstrationen auch auf auflagen der
ordnungsbehörden pfeift das ist mir auch
wieder viel zu undifferenziert bei
diesen demonstrationen vor dem reichstag
sind menschen dabei gewesen ich kenne
einen fall von einem von einem gastwirt
der damit demonstriert ist und in die
wasserwerfer gekommen ist das ist
einfach zu undifferenziert das alles für
leute zu halten die irgendwie spinnen
das klang aus der neunten rede heraus
nein da sind viele dabei die nicht
wissen wie es weitergehen soll und deren
solidarität oder die erwarten unsere
solidarität und da ist die beschimpfung
als sozusagen verschwörungstheoretiker
und leute mit dem man sie nicht gemein
machen soll mir einfach zu einfach
ja es gibt auch bei diesen corona
demonstrationen leute mit denen ich auch
nicht gemeinsam demonstrieren würde aber
es gibt eben sehr viele bürgerliche
leute die durch die maßnahmen auch sich
ungerecht behandelt fühlen
nehmen sie die gastwirte die alle regeln
umgesetzt haben alle abstandsregeln und
die nun doch wieder in den log daten
geschickt worden
und wenn die leute auf die straße gehen
und protestieren
und sie werden dann von wasserwerfern
empfangen dann ist es mir zu einfach
wenn herr leuten sagt macht euch nicht
mit diesen leuten gemacht
ja aber diese demonstranten könnte man
ja auch als rechtsbrecher bezeichnen
denn sie haben keine masken getragen sie
haben nicht auf abstand gehalten die
demonstration wurde aufgelöst und müssen
die demonstranten diesen platz verlassen
das haben sie nicht getan
die afg hört man immer wieder sei die
rechtsstaatspartei finden so richtig
dass die afg sich ich sage in dem fall
jetzt von rechtsbrechern die polizei und
der rechtsstaat sich von rechtsbrechern
auf der nase rumtanzen lassen erklärt
das sind jetzt plötzlich alles
rechtsbrecher nein nur die demonstranten
die in langen sind obwohl sie hätten
gehen müssen die mal ich kenne sind
keine rechtlich rede speziell von diesem
fall das ist schwierig das will ich gern
zugeben ja natürlich muss man den
anordnungen der polizei folgen kommt man
bei allem friedliche demonstranten
auch wenn sie die masken nicht getragen
haben alle dann mit wasserwerfern behagt
da hätte ich meine zweifel
und vor allen dingen wenn ich mir
angucke wie demonstrationen manchmal
noch in berlin zum ersten mal oder in
hamburg wie mit ihnen umgegangen wird
dann kann ich nur sagen ist mir das zu
undifferenziert dass man sagt er das
sind einfach rechtsbrecher ja das sind
leute die schwierigkeiten haben mit der
umsetzung dieser dinge ja und man muss
auch wenn man dabei ist darauf einwirken
dass sie sich an die gesetze halten
aber sie einfach sozusagen abzutun als
leute mit denen man am besten nichts zu
tun haben soll das finde ich falsch also
gut um das klarzustellen also auch
gewalttätige demonstranten am erstmals
in der rechtsbrecher es geht ja hier
nicht um politische zeiten richtig aber
da ist die berliner polizei jedenfalls
nicht so hart vorgegangen
diesmal war es nicht so aber früher
nicht so hart vorgegangen wie in dem
fall jetzt vor dem reichstag wenn wir
jetzt diesen leuten räte gehört haben
wie es jetzt auf dem parteitag weiter
geht es gibt ja viele konfliktlinien
auch gerade bei dem rentenkonzept ist ja
nicht alles da es muss eine nachfolge
von andreas kalbitz gewählt werden ist
da jetzt endgültig durch die räte von
jörg meuten der innerparteiliche
machtkampf losgetreten worden
ausgerechnet zehn monate vor der
bundestagswahl
ich weiß nicht ob projekt wollten die
absicht hatte einen innerparteilichen
machtkampf loszutreten jedenfalls hat er
seine rede wenn ich die reaktion im
plenum sei falsch eingeschätzt sie
könnte so wirken ich glaube gar nicht
dass er das in der absicherung gewollt
hat aber ja die gefahr besteht dass wir
uns in diesen lagern verkämpfen
und ich hätte mir von new york leuten
eine rede gewünscht die die einheit der
partei in den vordergrund stellt bei
aller kritik an einzelnen dingen die man
haben und machen kann
aber zuerst muss ich doch mal an die
einheit appellieren
ich hatte nicht das gefühl dass das was
er da gesagt hat in irgendeiner weise
als aufbruch für uns wird und ich
erwarte vom bundessprecher dass er
sozusagen einen aufbruch formuliert und
bei der kritik jedenfalls vorsichtig ist
und nicht viele leute und er hat viele
leute im plenum vor den kopf gestoßen
aber wie kann er die kann ein
parteivorsitzender über die einheit
einer partei sprechen wenn in dieser
partei im moment ziemlich viel
zwietracht herrscht das ist lieber herr
keller seiner aufgabe ja ich habe auch
in dieser brandenburgischen landtags
fraktionen wie jetzt in der
bundestagsfraktion
schwierige fälle man muss bis zuletzt um
die einheit kämpfen und nicht sozusagen
von vornherein dass verloren geben und
morgens rede klang leider so als ob sich
jetzt eine gruppe gegen die andere
durchsetzen muss und das halte ich für
falsch
soweit alexander gauland über die rede
seines amtsvorgängers als
parteivorsitzender von jörg leuten die
rede
ich bedanke mich dass sie daran